how to promote your books without
spending any money so I got a question
from one of my newsletter readers love
you guys Denise who wrote in the say hi
Evan essentially what I want to ask is
that because my earnings from my book
are so low I actually have a negative
profit margin I spent a fair amount on
my book trailer professional editing and
so on so how do I conduct an efficient
publicity campaign without too much
expenditure my book is called Eternal
and is the first of a young adult
fantasy Trilogy with an Arthurian flavor
there's lots of information about it on
my website Eternal luck.com including
two book trailers thanks again Evan have
a lovely evening kind wishes Denise
Denise this is such a great question and
one that a lot of artists struggle with
and you're you're an artist through your
writing other people are artists through
their music artists through their their
paintings or through their digital art
we're all artists and
artists really have a hard time often
getting their artwor out there and
appreciated it and it's not because it's
not good work it could be amazing work
but it's because you don't have the
marketing communication skills to let
people know about what you're doing so
I'm going to give you three bits of
advice to help you get more well known
with your book without having to spend a
lot of money because what you need to do
is get your book to touch people and
that doesn't have to cost anything so
number one is stand for something this
is so important there are so many
authors out there there are so many
books there are so many young adult
fiction books out there why should I
care about yours over everybody else how
do you rise above the noise and it's
going to be standing for something what
do you the niece stand for how can you
sum that up in one word right what's
your one word what's the common theme
that is across all of your books what am
I going to learn what's a teachable
lesson for me why are you writing these
books make me connect to it make me feel
like it's important when people write a
book when people create any art when I'm
making my art my artist through these
videos when you're making art it comes
from an emotional place it comes from a
desire to do something right to make the
world a better place somehow to get your
story out there's an emotional
connection that you feel in creating
your art it has to be if that's not
there then don't create the art if
you're just writing a book cuz I want to
write a book it's not going to be suc
successful it's got to come from a deep
emotional place for you so what is that
maybe you're showing kids that they
should believe in their dreams maybe
you're you're helping them boost their
confidence maybe you are just giving
them a place to escape to to escape your
your your daily life like whatever it is
that has to be important to you there
has to be something important I know
there is there's something there but you
have to express it and let me know and
when you're writing into me or you're
writing to anybody it's not just me when
you're communicating your message you
say I'm a young adult writer fiction
writer who believes
that what what do you believe kids
should follow their
dreams kids need to have more
self-confidence and you express that
through the way you know how which is
through your books and it's not a
self-help here are the five steps but by
learning through the stories of the
characters in your books I'm being a
better person I'm learning how to be
better there has to be some guiding core
and so you have to let that out and you
have to express and that has to be on
your website that's has to be in all
your marketing all your Communications
to make it easy for people to understand
you and when people see that they're
either going to connect to it or they
won't and that's fine but the people who
connect to it they now have a reason to
talk about you and you're making it easy
for them to talk about you so you have
to first figure out what you stand for
and then put it on all of your marketing
materials so one is stand for something
number two is use social
media it's never been easier to spread a
message but you have to have that
message worth spreading right that goes
back to number one you have your message
now I would start reaching out to people
who believe in the same thing you do so
if your books were about believe you
want to talk to me right if you wrote to
me inste I'm a young uh adult fantasy
writer and I write books that helps help
kids believe in
themselves I'd want to know you I would
want to have you on my radio show I'd
want to do videos about you I'd want to
check out your books if I go to your
website and it's all about
believe perfect we got to find a way to
work together somehow and other people
who have the same cause as you that's
what they're going to see some people
might go and say believe some people hit
my website they see believe and they say
what is this this is stupid this is
crazy that's fine you know what those
people won't like your book anyway but
you're making it it easier for people
who are aligned to your mission to
connect to you and spread the word cuz
right now you're just an author who
doesn't stand for anything you have to
stand out so make that list of all the
people who talk about the same thing you
do through their own way through social
media they have the same message but
they just attack it from a different
angle those are the people who you want
to connect with comment on share your
stories encourage them be part of their
conversations that they're posting and
people people continuously respond to me
on Facebook or Twitter on YouTube I
check out their page I'm curious who is
this person who's leaving all these
comments and if I went and I saw that
your message is all about believe I'd
have to find a way to work together and
other people want to do the same thing
if they feel connected to you so you
have to make that targeted list and
start reaching out and sharing with
people so that's two use social media
number three is use traditional media
traditional media is still a great way
to get your message out and for every
single story that gets put out the media
is looking for experts they want experts
right they want people to come on and
and add their perspective and whatever
topic you are trying to approach right
whatever LED you to write about young
fiction your young adult fiction you
could be the expert for that right and
again it's connecting the media because
there's tons of young adult fiction
writers when you know what you stand for
and what makes you different when you
are writing to the media and you're
commenting on the articles that they
write and you're introducing yourself
when you're sharing your stories they're
going to be connected to your mission
they're going to remember you they're
going to know you as Denise she's the
copywriter or the the author who stands
for this and it's going to be so much
easier for them to remember you to call
on you when they have stories that come
up to engage with you especially when
they're already writing things that are
related to the topics that you talk
about in your book so three use
traditional media so in in summary
number one stand for something number
two use social media and number three
use traditional media none of these
things cost anything but your time and
when you figure out your message and you
communicate it properly people will
connect to it people will share it and
your book will explode believe for those
of you watching like this video you can
subscribe to the channel to see more
videos like this thank you so much I'll
see you
soon